Today,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we move back to northern Europe to the northern part of the former Roman empire.
And,
uh,
since you've done the reading,
I won't be giving anything away by saying that the culmination of what we're
talking about is Charlemagne and Charlemagne,
his coronation in Rome at the hands of the pope in the year 800,
uh,
as emperor.
We'll talk about what that title means.
A title that had not been seen in 325 years in the West,
at least not in an the agreed upon
by everyone in western Europe.
Charlemagne at this time didn't control quite everything in western Europe.
You have a map in the Wickham book of his empire,
uh,
bequeath to his successors,
in the year eight 43 the year that it is partitioned.
This,
uh,
is,
does not include the British isles.
Uh,
it does not include most of Spain,
which was in Islamic hands.
Uh,
but it is a,
um,
pretty convincing effort at the restoration of the Roman empire,
even though it's base.
In other words,
where Charlemagne and his ancestors lands were,
where their wealth came from,
where they lived,
where their followers came from,
was uh,
at what had been the borders of the Roman Empire.
Uh,
what's now northeastern France,
Belgium,
the Netherlands,
west north western Germany,
a territory known at this time as our Straw Zia Charlemagne,
his ancestors were great men.
Major nobles of the region of our straws.
Yeah.
Again,
eastern France,
western Germany,
the low country.
They were nominal servants of the mirror.
Vingean rulers
and rose to prominence with eight title of my or and Wickham preserves just the
Latin [inaudible] major,
larger,
great man.
The mire of the palace,
the mayor of the palace is how this is usually translated.
And of course our word mayor,
it applies to a municipal official.
So mayor of the palace is a rather funny title,
but it's really a kind of prime minister or leader of the soldiers,
prime minister and defense secretary or a minister.
And this title tended to be hereditary.
One of the problems of rulers in the mirror.
Vingean world in the Lombard world,
in,
in all of western Europe is controlling their mighty servants.
Because these people were not just easy to fire.
You couldn't just cut their salaries.
I mean,
or you know,
stopped their paycheck because they're not getting a paycheck.
They're the leaders of soldiers.
They young castles,
fortifications.
But most of all they own land and those land owners and as established powers
within the society,
their power rivals and in the case of Charlemagne's ancestors would exceed the
power of the king.
So these are not people who are easy to dislodge and they are people who tend to
want their power to be not appointive but hereditary.
In other words,
to be queef titles like mayor of the palace to their sons
will,
I mentioned this now because next week we'll see this is a problem that
Charlemagne,
his descendants would have.
They would have the same problem.
How do you make your officials that you've appointed listen to you obey your
orders if you don't have sufficient coercive power to remove them?
The reason you don't have sufficient course of power to remove them again is
because they aren't military officials.
They have their own followers,
they are well established in various territories and so they're hard to tame.
They are becoming little kings themselves.
And the key aspect of the ability to become a local ruler,
even though officially you're subject to the real king
of a large realm,
uh,
is because it's become hereditary.
It's become a family property.
This tendency to decentralization inheritance and we can,
royal power is often called feudalism,
a word that you may as well write down.
You've heard of it.
Uh,
but which we're not going to use and we're not going to use it for couple of
reasons.
One of which is,
uh,
nobody uses the term at the time.
It carries a lot of other overtones that are not,
are not relevant to us.
And it really in so far as it has use,
it's describes a later period,
a history to 11 kind of reality.
A post year 1000.
But what is to be recalled is that once you no longer have an official state
apparatus with an administrative structure or bureaucracy like Diocletian,
like Constantine,
like Justinian or even like those Byzantine emperors we were talking about,
or like the avast had collar fet.
All of those are complex structures of state bureaucracies funded by taxation.
Here we have something that is not that sort of politics.
It is more personal.
It is more military.
It depends more on plunder,
on expansion,
on charisma,
that is personal ability to get people to obey you.
It has a very rudimentary structure and the success of a state is judged on the
basis of its ability to survive.
Even if the ruler doesn't have charisma,
even if the ruler is not all that great,
because people obey the state,
they obey its officials,
they will be at bay.
The idea of the state and not the individual personality.
So we're going to talk about Charlemagne,
his ancestors,
and how they got into power,
how they went from being a mighty servants,
but servants nonetheless to kings of France.
And eventually in 800 emperors,
what happened to the Merovingians last time we checked,
the mayor of Indians were certainly kicking people around,
uh,
Frankia,
um,
warring with each other,
occasionally regretting it,
burning the tax roles,
but pretty quickly returning to the old,
uh,
plunder in killing people and having fun kind of barbarian economy.
The late mayor of,
and the mayor of engine dynasty lasts to the mid eighth century,
but for its last hundred years,
roughly six 52,
seven 50.
Um,
its rulers are ineffective.
They have the title kings,
they have great prestige,
but they are weak.
A lot of our understanding of their position really is simply a gloss or an
elaboration of a few lines of Einhard.
The biographer of Charlemagne whom you've read the family of the mayor of
engines.
He says on page 16 of this book from which the Franks used to make their kings
is thought to have lasted down to king killed Derek,
whom Pope Steven ordered deposed his long hair was short and he was forced into
a monastery.
Remember,
one of the symbols of Merovingian familial prestige was this long hair.
The Carolingian had short hair and wore mustaches.
They kind of broke with the mirror of engine look,
but of course this is not just a male fashion statement,
although it might seem that the marriage of engine family ended with him.
It had in fact been without any vitality for a long time.
The Mirror of engines,
we're just given a little shock because they were already basically finished.
There was nothing of any worth
okay
in it except for the empty name of King.
For both the riches and power of the kingdom were in possession of the prefix of
the palace.
This is how he's translating it,
who were called the mayors of the pals and to them fell the highest command.
Nothing was left for the king to do except just sit on his throne with his hair
long and his beard uncut,
satisfied to hold the name of king only and pretending to rule,
except for the empty name of King and a meager living allowance,
which the Prophet of the court extended to him.
He possessed nothing else of his own,
but one the state in a very small income.
Now,
so much depends on these words of iron,
who then goes on to describe them going around in these ceremonial cards.
Uh,
people are claiming them,
but everybody knows that if they want anything done,
the person to talk to is the mayor of the palace.
It's too Einhard's interest,
or at least to the interest of the Carolingian is for whom he's writing to make
it appear as if the mayor of engines,
we're already finished.
But nevertheless,
it's clear that they were much weaker than the people we've been reading about
in Gregory of tour.
What happened to them?
Well,
one possibility that,
uh,
Einhard in effect sort of encourages as that they,
they just,
you know,
something happened to the family.
They,
they,
uh,
they were weak personalities and you know,
maybe they had some hereditary yeah.
Degeneration,
um,
or they ran out of money.
They did not have lands to reward their followers anymore.
Remember that in this economy,
uh,
this is not something in which tax revenues are funding the state.
I mean,
up to a point they are because we saw,
uh,
that a Fred a guns and kill Parak had tax revenues and these tax records to
burn.
But as the inheritance of Rome,
Roman administration,
Roman literacy,
Roman organization frayed,
has that inheritance became further and further degraded.
The ability to tax the population rural dispersed,
uh,
dwindled.
So it's not only a question of the administrative decline,
but if the economic decline or at least the economic decentralization of the way
people lived,
the mirror of Indians had depended on awful lot on war and on the plunder
received from the more you'll remember that when we were talking about a Clo
Tar,
uh,
the son of Clovis,
that his men rebelled when he didn't want to fight the Saxons.
That's not just because they're war like savages or in so far is there war like
savages?
They're also in it for treasure plunder bay.
A Wolf is a plunder driven world.
The author of Beowulf is well aware that this is stupid in a way,
right?
The dragon has all this plunder and what does he do with it?
You know,
dragons are not consumers.
Uh,
he,
you know,
he lies on beds of uh,
uh,
gold coins and you know,
beautiful armor and,
uh,
all sorts of things that have been seized has absolutely no use for all of this
stuff.
And yet stealing just a little tiny ring or a little bit of it enrages him.
And so he starts his depredations out of anger at that the Merovingians,
once they stop expanding,
don't have the opportunities to keep their economy going,
their source of income going and in particular,
they lose the ability.
So it would seem to reward their followers,
their followers,
their nights to call them that anachronistic way.
Their military entourage
does not flourish by being paid because there's very little in the way of
coinage.
There's very little in the way of revenues.
Okay?
They benefit from things like land,
but as you are running out of plunder and giving away land,
then sooner or later you yourself,
the giver of land will not have any more to give.
That's another hypothesis about,
uh,
Merovingian decline.
In fact,
uh,
there is a,
an effort by a mayor of the palace of the late seventh century to depose the
mayor of engine king,
um,
Amanda and grim old
who is an ancestor of Charlemagne.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this unsuccessful,
okay?
He tries to depose a mirror of engine ruler and even though the Merovingians are
weak,
there are other followers prevent grim old from succeeding.
And indeed he's executed.
The prestige of the Merovingians was suck that even if they were not effective,
they were still the kings because the blood of Clovis float in their veins.
And this was symbolized by their familial distinctiveness.
We concluded the long hair,
the uncut beard,
the traveling around in carcass.
Yeah.
This is important because it means that you could not succeed by direct action
against the Merovingians,
at least not in six 61 when old.
Uh,
was,
um,
uh,
killed
in order to make this happen.
Now,
other words,
even though he was killed,
his successors remained as mayors.
The palace,
they were a tightly enough ensconced or,
um,
uh,
inserted into the structures of power and successful enough as a family,
but they were able to survive.
But as mayors of the palace looked at from the long term,
that is from the perspective of seven 51 the year when Pepin,
uh,
declared himself king of the Franks and deposed that last Merovingian ruler
looked at from that perspective,
the strategy of the dynasty,
which we can call Carolinians even though we're not yet at Charlemagne,
the strategy of the Carolingian was to come up with another rationale,
another rationale for why they should be kings and not the mayor of income,
what we can call legitimacy.
Legitimacy in politics is the sense that the people who are ruling our ruling
for good reasons,
that their rule is legitimate.
This can be on the basis of an election.
I may not like the president,
but he was elected in a fair election.
Therefore,
accept the fact that he's president.
It may be,
um,
uh,
triumph and war.
Okay.
This emperor came to power,
deposed his predecessor and got the Bulgars off our back.
Therefore,
his rule is legitimate.
Uh,
it may be economic benefit.
this guy has a,
uh,
um,
made my life easier economically,
or,
you know,
I have the feeling that things are going right.
It may be dynasty.
This,
uh,
is,
the oldest son of the former king,
or you know,
the British rulers just changed to admit,
uh,
um,
to end discrimination between men and women in the succession.
So,
uh,
the,
um,
you know,
obviously Britain has a queen rather than a king and has for the last 60 years,
but,
um,
uh,
the favored candidate would be a male child.
The circumstances of Elizabeth's succession don't need to detain us,
but,
uh,
she was not the logical eldest,
um,
obviously not the eldest male child.
So there all sorts of ways of having legitimacy as a ruler.
The challenge for the mayors of the palace was to,
um,
create this legitimacy
and they did it by several different means.
Uh,
it's not that there's this project where they set out in year six,
62 and say,
within 90 years we're coming to power and here's how we're going to do it.
Uh,
it is historians who impose that rational strategy,
but nevertheless,
it is discernible.
In fact,
there are mayors of the palace of several different pieces because the mirror of
engine realm was not unified.
It was in particular pieces.
So these guys are the mayors of the palace of all straws.
Yeah.
So there were opponents include the other kingdoms,
particularly new Austria,
which is more or less the region of Paris,
the sen,
the central to northern part of modern France,
but further west.
And then I'll straws here.
So I'll,
Strozzi is northeast,
new street is more central,
uh,
and slightly south.
Okay.
So there are lots of rivals.
It's a very dangerous situation.
It's a very violent world.
But this is their plan.
A lot of what they,
um,
that is the Carolingian ancestors of Charlemagne accomplished was military.
This is the bottom line of leadership in the period where dealing with without
military prestige and military success,
it's very hard to craft a polity,
let alone hand that down to your descendants.
Okay.
What is more unusual than military leadership?
However,
is that the Carolingian allied themselves to the church,
their legitimacy as rulers would be based very much on an alliance with the
church.
And in particular with the papacy,
the bishop of Rome is someone whom we haven't talked about very much.
We mentioned Leo the first back in the fifth century,
who was responsible for negotiating with the huns in the absence of the emperor
and who also upheld Doc Trinal,
uh,
orthodoxy against monophysitism.
But the pope was not inevitably the sole ruler of the church and the way he
would become in the modern world within the Catholic Church.
The pope was a,
the bishop of Rome.
He was the guardian of some of the chief relics of the Christian world,
the relics of Saint Peter and Saint Paul.
The apostle's.
Yeah.
He was the inheritor of the aura of the city of Rome,
the imperial city.
He even had appropriated some titles from the Roman emperor such as Pontifex
Maximus,
an old pagan title.
So the pope is the inheritor of a lot of Roman imperial prestige,
but he is a beleaguered inheritor of that.
In fact,
the pope's life in Rome was dangerous.
He was often,
um,
uh,
eclipsed by or threatened by the Lombards,
the Lombards,
a barbarian tribe who had invaded Italy.
We talked about them last time.
Uh,
they invaded in five 68.
They took most of Italy from Justinian's heirs.
Uh,
they were airing on for a longer time than other barbarian tribes.
And even when they cease to be Arion,
they were eager to seize Rome.
They weren't overwhelmingly eager to see run because they never did it,
but they threatened
the pope.
During the seventh century,
the pope considered himself the ally of the Byzantine Empire.
The emperor is continue to intervene to debate various stock trinal things.
But as the Lombard threat grew,
as the Byzantine emperors were iconoclast,
the pope cast around for a new protector beginning in really the seven twenties,
seven 30.
And so the alliance between Carolingian and popes is natural in the sense that
they both want something out of the other.
But Carolingian owns the mayors of the palace want legitimacy.
They want to be sacred figures within the Christian world to Trump the pre
Christian or a of the mayor of engines.
And the pope out of the Carolingian wants protection from the lombards and a
sense of,
uh,
rule over most of Europe that will favor the church and allow the church to
advance its work.
The means of cementing this alliance,
however,
are interestingly enough,
mom,
the people who are the shock troops of the Christianization of Europe,
the expansion of Europe,
uh,
of the church and the furtherance of its mission are monks.
Many of them from Ireland and Britain who would try to convert the countryside,
either those places that were minimally Christian or beginning of the seventh,
late seventh and early 18th centuries,
extend Christianity to places like Holland or,
um,
central Germany
that were not part of the Roman empire and had never been Christian.
So these monastic settlements not only converted the countryside,
but they served as photo psi for economic and social development.
There was an alliance between the mayors of the palace and monks such as the
English monk,
St Barna Fests,
apostle to the Germans.
Saint Bonhoeffer's in the eighth century would convert a lot of the Germans in
an east of the Rhine.
He would receive support from the mayors of the Palace of Australia because this
is east of where they are and they're interested in expanding and settling there
and he received support from the pope who is interested in the conversion of
Christians and so it's through intermediaries like Saint Boniface and other
monks.
The countryside gets converted and that the Carroll and jeans and the pope
approach each other.
Why monks?
Who are these guys?
When we looked at the benedictine role,
didn't it seem as if monks are supposed to be enclosed in their monasteries and
not wander around?
These are somewhat special monks.
These are wandering monks.
The Irish tradition was different from the Benedictine tradition and encourage
wandering as a form of penance.
If you want it to do penance or to experience the power of God and randomness in
the world,
which would you rather do pray seven times a day in the same place for decades?
Or just kind of like,
um,
okay.
Wander around,
try to convert people and see if you could get martyred.
Uh,
certainly the latter is dangerous.
The ladder is truly dangerous.
Uh,
but his are very enterprising guys.
You know,
we just,
we just have this idea,
oh yeah,
amongst pray or are they copying manuscripts or they wander around and convert
people,
all of which are insanely difficult things to do.
And you really have to admire these guys.
Um,
so,
uh,
there are,
many of them are from Ireland or from recently converted Anglo Saxon England.
Saxon England combines a benedictine structure with some of this inheritance of
Irish,
uh,
wandering.
But it is these monasteries that are founded in the countryside of Germany,
of the Netherlands.
Um,
and the alliances between the mayors of the palace and the papacy that are key
in
creating the Carolingian dynasty,
uh,
the mayors of the palace of a Straw Zia come to preeminence in the mirror
vingean realms in the early eighth century.
One of the key events here is one that we've looked at from several sides now,
and that will be,
I hope,
familiar to you.
And that is the battle of Poitier in seven 33 also known as the battle of tour.
This is the battle in which the Arabs were defeated in northern France and
eventually retreated to Spain.
Seven 33 marks the high water point of Arab incursions into Europe and is in a
sense of parallel to seven 17,
the defeat of the siege of Constantinople.
Okay.
The victor at Poitier was the mayor of the Palace of Australia,
a man named Charles Martel,
the hammer.
He doesn't have a last name.
It's sort of a
Charles Martel.
And he gained tremendous prestige,
firmness that legitimation that we said comes from military leadership.
Certainly,
uh,
was his,
the Merovingian king was nowhere to be seen at that battle.
It was led by the mayor of the palace,
Charles,
his son,
Pepin the short started really to put together these aspects of a rule,
Pepin the short,
um,
seven 41 to seven 68.
Now there's something going on here that I don't have an explanation for.
Uh,
if he really was short yet,
we know from a,
um,
digging up his body that Charlemagne was on the order of six,
seven.
Charlemagne is really tall,
uh,
for a premodern people.
He's really,
really trying to,
I'm the 900 describes him as tall.
Einhard says,
you know,
his voice was kind of squeaky and high given just how huge he was.
I Dunno how that works.
Um,
many of you are more advanced in the science in genetics and name,
but,
uh,
my pet theory since pepins body hasn't been fat is that actually he was really
tall too,
and that he's called Pepin the short as a kind of joke.
You know,
like guys nicknamed tiny,
uh,
are often,
you know,
like 350 pounders.
I'm just saying,
uh,
Pepin the short is the person who crystallizes this potential alliance among
papacy,
missionaries and mayors of the palace.
And in doing so,
he transforms Europe.
He favored the church.
He could mobilize his new power and legitimacy through this alliance with the
church.
He encouraged various kinds of monastic reforms or by Saint Barnabas,
which meant better discipline over a priests,
more councils of bishops.
Okay.
The restoration of lands to the church
and a role for the king as the Guardian and protector of the church.
Okay.
It may be at manifests as in,
um,
instigation that Pepin wrote to the pope.
Zacharias at this time asking,
is it right for the man who holds the power not to wear the crown while the
person who wrote where's the crown does not hold the power.
Okay.
He asks this as if it was a hypothetical question.
Oh,
you know,
we were just discussing this last night and wonder what you think.
Uh,
but of course the pope is quite aware of what's at stake and says it is wrong
for the person who holds the power not to hold the crown.
Where upon in seven 51 Pepin had himself elected king of the Franks,
okay.
Deposed and put in a monastery.
The last Merovingian king and by is being put in the monastery.
He was Tom Shirt.
That is to say his,
uh,
much of his hair was cut off.
D sacralizing him
and unlike grim olds failed coup d'etat,
this was totally peacefully,
no problem.
Greeted by everybody,
uh,
successful.
In seven 53,
two years later,
the new pope,
Steven made an unprecedented,
literally unprecedented journey across the Alps.
No pope had ever been in northern Europe until this year.
And he crowned Peppa,
he was desperate over the situation with the lombards
and in return,
Pepin led an expedition that although not the definitive invasion of Italy that
Charlemagne would undertake a,
at least gave the pope some breathing room and defeated the lombards.
Yeah.
At pepins death in seven 68,
he was succeeded by his son Charles and his other son Carmen Charles the future.
Charles the Great Charlotte [inaudible].
Yeah,
Carla man died in [inaudible] 70 [inaudible] 71.
Uh,
maybe naturally,
maybe not leaving Charlemagne as the sole ruler.
Charlemagne at this point is king of the Franks inheritor of the title and
accomplishments of his father.
He was the beneficiary then of well over a hundred years of,
uh,
Carolingian ascent.
And let's just review the factors that had aided his predecessors.
The weakness of the mayor of engines,
their position is mayors of the palace.
Yeah.
The activity of monks,
missionaries to Germany and the eastern part of the Frankish World
Byzantine weakness and the Lombard threat.
And of course Byzantine flirting with,
uh,
heresies like iconoclasm.
The result is then a kind of geopolitical shift of the papacy towards the north,
another chapter in that long book of the end of Mediterranean hegemony instead
of looking to the eastern Mediterranean for protection and for the ruler who was
his natural ally,
the pope now looks to a northern Trans Alpine ruler.
Charlemagne you've read about,
uh,
and you've read Einhard's biography of him.
It is,
uh,
in some sense,
at least a seemingly artless biography.
He obviously likes him admire somebody,
describes him as a real person.
I mean,
we learned that he liked baths,
uh,
and a roast meat,
that he had a high voice,
uh,
that he loved having his daughters around him,
but probably kind of mistreated them by not allowing them to marry.
And then 900 scandalized that since they couldn't marry,
they had all sorts of,
you know,
guys hanging around.
Um,
we get a sense of Charlemagne.
His personality.
Charlemagne is,
Amen.
Very much at in his time.
He is comfortable with being a warrior.
He would lead campaigns year after year after year at the same time.
He is a person of learning or at least a person who believes learning is
important.
Einhard tells us that he never quite really learned to read and write that he
tried,
but he slept with Augustine's city of God by his side,
which is an impressive thing to do as a bedtime reading.
Um,
and we also know that he's pious.
His piety does not interfere with his enjoyment of life or with his,
uh,
harsh,
prosecution of military campaigns.
He's not a sensitive person.
He's not an,
uh,
self,
um,
uh,
examining kind of character.
But very important is that his notion of leadership combines the what might be
thought of three available forms of legitimacy of this era.
One is,
and the most important is military prestige and power
war leadership.
And he conquered lots of peoples.
It was not just a question of war leadership with no results.
He had tremendous results.
He conquered the Lombards in Italy in seven 74 he conquered the Avon ours in the
70s.
So much treasure did he sees from that.
Remember we saw the vars as procedures of Constantinople.
By this time they're in more or less modern Hungary.
He sees so much treasure that the entire economy of his empire,
basically a was financed on the basis of this plunder until his death in eight
14.
So for nearly 20 years,
he conquered the Bavarians.
He conquered the Saxons in northern eastern Germany.
Very,
very difficult series of campaigns from seven 74 to eight oh six that involved,
um,
uh,
large numbers of civilian casualties,
virtual exterminations of peoples and forced conversion.
It was the first real sustained campaign of forced conversion to Christianity in
European history.
Brutal,
but successful opening up really the definition of modern Germany.
Much of what the modern German state is,
uh,
in its central and eastern parts in the north is Saxon.
There is a part called Saxony,
still a province of the former East Germany,
but in fact,
uh,
a province of the former or alarmed as they're called of the former West Germany
is called Kneaders oxen Lower Saxony.
Uh,
so the Saxons are spread throughout northern Germany and by Charlemagne his
death,
Germany or the eastern Frankish realm starts to look something like,
uh,
something familiar.
Uh,
he conquers a bit in Spain against the Muslims.
His forces would seize Barcelona in the year eight Oh one,
but he does not get as far as he had hoped.
In particular,
he had hoped to take Sarah Gosa.
His army was defeated by a actually Basques,
but their defeat weeds to the literary triumph known as the song of Roland,
one of the great works of the Middle Ages in which the enemy are Muslims.
And the song of Roland is a great sort of crusade ideology text,
which shows in its own words that Christians are right.
Pagans are wrong.
Of course they call the Muslims Pagans.
They depict them as worshiping Apollo and term of guns and other,
uh,
gods.
They know that the Muslims are not literally pagans,
but uh,
it has higher rhetorical valued.
Charlemagne is tremendously successful as a ward leader.
Then his second form of power and legitimacy is as a Christian ruler.
He is a man with a vision of a Christian polity
of alliance with the church and as seeing himself as responsible for the
spiritual health of his people.
This is important,
this latter responsibility because it has a lot to do with the program of
education that we'll be talking about next week.
The intellectual heir of his court.
He believes himself,
therefore to be not just somebody who is supposed to convert the Saxons
forcibly,
but it's supposed to educate as population into becoming a Christians have a
real sword.
This also means that he is allied with the pope and believes that the pope is
capable of aiding him in more than merely symbolic way.
The third aspect of power and legitimacy is the legacy of Rome,
which is the thing that unifies this entire course.
Charlemagne,
according to Einhard,
went to Rome to rescue the pope,
yet again.
Now,
not this time from the lombards in 800,
but from the Roman factions.
Pope Leo the third
was rescued by Charlemagne,
put back in Rome.
Charlemagne Einhard tells us,
went to Saint Peter's on Christmas Day to pray.
And Lo and behold,
the pope jumped out from behind a pillar and put the crown on his head.
And he was a claimed Roman emperor.
Charlemagne said later he wouldn't have gone,
even though it was Christmas.
He wouldn't have gone to church at all if he'd known this was going to happen.
Uh,
we can be cynical about the surprise aspect of this or about Charlemagne's
uncharacteristic modesty.
Nevertheless,
we have to think about the implications of the pope crowning the Emperor
Constantine wasn't crowned by a pope.
Um,
the problem with having someone crown you is that it could be implied that he is
the one who bestows the crown and could decide not to crown someone in the
future.
It looks as if he's the more powerful one.
He's standing,
he's putting the crown on you and you're kneeling indeed as an avocation of this
almost exactly 1000 years later in 1804 when Napoleon had himself crowned by the
Pope,
uh,
Napoleon sees the crown from the pope's hands and put it on his himself,
put it on his own head in a direct reference to Charlemagne.
So Roman Christian and military leadership of these,
the Roman is the most impressive and the most sort of historically dramatic,
but probably the least significant.
At the time,
Charlemagne did not consider his empire to be exactly the same thing as the
Roman empire.
He would divide it.
Uh,
the fact that he handed it over to one son is that he only ended up having one
surviving son,
but he had plans to divided.
It's not clear if he regarded the imperial titles,
anything that would,
we're really survive.
Nevertheless,
he was an emperor,
an emperor,
meaning that he ruled over many peoples.
He was more than just the king of the Franks because he now ruled over
barbarians.
A Varas visit.
Goffs Lombard's.
He had made a good stab at restoring the Roman Empire in the west,
but
it's a different Roman empire.
It's base is not really in Rome nor even in Milan or Ravenna,
the late Roman imperial capitols of the fifth century.
It is in
a city,
um,
in Australia,
uh,
where,
remains of his palace chapel still stand.
His lands,
influence cronies,
family,
political base,
economic base,
military recruiting base are all in northern Europe.
Charlemagne is then in some sense the reviver of the Roman empire,
but he is also the founder of Europe as something,
not just a geographical expression,
but a cultural expression,
whether it is a sociopolitical expression.
Um,
time will tell when the European Union,
the euro and all these things that are sort of semi unraveling.
Now we're cemented in their current form in the early 19 nine days in the,
uh,
the treaties that established that we're deliberately made in the territories
that are neither French nor German entirely,
but are really part of the old Carolingian patrimony that treaties in places
like Maastricht,
uh,
the location of Brussels as the capital of the European Union.
All of this is really evocative of the empire of Charlemagne.
These are the lands of,
uh,
um,
the Carolingian and this is in the next thousand years in certain respects,
the center of Europe.
We'll talk more about the Carolinians next week.